every time you talk about Israel versus
Palestine if you don't take a side
people automatically assume that you
support one side or you support murder
so I want to make this Crystal Clear
before I get into this video hey guys
and welcome back to the Le High pan show
so today is going to be a little bit of
a different video as you can probably
tell from the title so I want to talk
about what is going on in the Middle
East right now because things are
kicking off between Israel and Palestine
now I want to give quite a unique
perspective on what's happening over
there as I've actually previously lived
in Israel and actually visit visited
many times and I'm also going to expose
the dark truth about the geopolitics
that's going on in that region but
before I get into this video I do want
to let you know that often my content
gets censored and taken down that's why
I've created my very own free and
private Community where I talk about all
the different things that we're not
allowed to talk about online inside this
community we also talk about how to make
your first $10,000 a month online how to
build a personal brand and I also share
the different crypto and FX trades that
my team and I make so if you are
interested in leveling up financially
leveling up mentally then join my free
and private telegram group I'm going to
leave the link for you in the
description below every time you talk
about Israel versus Palestine if you
don't take a side people automatically
assume that you support one side or you
support murder so I want to make this
Crystal Clear before I get into this
video I do not support murder I do not
support grape I do not support the
torture and all the awful things
happening of innocent civilians women
and children I don't support any of it
on either side so let's just make that
clear before the comments section starts
to blow up I also think it's extremely
heartbreaking that innocent people get
caught up in the conflict of their
governments the Israeli government
versus Hamas the Palestinian authorities
the most fascinating thing about this
war right now is of course there's a war
we're seeing play out on the ground but
there's also a digital Warfare we're
seeing play out on the internet on both
sides there's so much propaganda
happening right now that people need to
be aware of for example I'm seeing on
Twitter I'm seeing fake video game
footage people claiming that this is
Hamas attacking Israel this is is Israel
attacking innocent civilians in Gaza
it's literally just a video game footage
I'm even seeing footage from 10 years
ago I'm seeing footage from soldiers
which aren't even Palestinian or Israeli
and this is so concerning because it's
dividing people even more on both sides
and it's resulting in people coming out
and calling for the murder of innocent
people I've seen people say online
flatten all of them I'm just seeing so
much propaganda and this propaganda is
literally changing the minds of people
so before I share my unique story which
I think will give a lot of insight and
information about what life is actually
like on the ground in a war zone I want
to just propose a few questions which I
will later to answer in this video my
first question is how did Israel not
know that an attack of this size was
coming Israel Prides itself on having
the best military in the world it Prides
itself of having the best surveillance
mad and yet it didn't know that an
attack of this scale was coming I cannot
understand that the Israeli military and
the Israeli intelligence agency must
literally have soldiers patrolling the
Gaza border they have surveillance
monitoring over the whole of the Gaza
Strip they know where every Hamas
militant terrorist whatever you want to
call them they know exactly where these
individuals are all the time they also
have a very sophisticated Navy system so
how was Hamas able to arrive in Israel
in boats Over the Sea paragliders coming
over the border of Gaza and bulldozing
down the Gaza border entering local
towns like stot and ashalon and when
they entered and they started killing
innocent civilians where was the Army
there were no soldiers on the ground
these are the questions that we have to
be asking on the Israeli side and I know
for a fact that there are always
soldiers and police on the ground
because I actually live there and I'm
going to share my unique story with you
in a bit but when I lived there there
were soldiers on the ground all the time
everywhere you go in Israel there's
police so I don't understand when Hamas
invaded on land and sea and brutally
murdered civilians women children why
there were no police there why there
were no soldiers there this is the
weirdest part to me now the game's being
played on the Palestinian side which you
need to be aware of is the foreign aid
the Biden Administration sent to Iran so
about a month ago the Biden
Administration sent $6 billion do in
foreign aid to Iran now if you're
unaware Iran is actually a supporter and
a backer of Hamas so all of a sudden
Hamas now have better intelligence
better military equipment and all of
this is now being used to invade Israel
and attack innocent women and children
so what we can learn from this is that
games are being played on both sides but
from the people at the top nobody wants
this war but there's clearly a game of
chess being played by the west and the
east from both sides and unfortunately
like with all Wars the people at the top
win because war is profitable and the
people at the bottom the innocent
civilians on both sides both in the Gaza
Strip and of course in
Israel they lose they die so what's the
lesson that we can learn from these two
questions that I've proposed so instead
of being divided and conquered by the
people at the top which is how they want
us to be for example being forced to
pick a side screaming death to the
Israelis death to the Palestinian and
engaging in all the propaganda online we
need to take a step back and objectively
observe the games being played out in
front of us you have the two governments
at the top the American government and
the Israeli government or some might say
it's only one player the American
government funding both sides who are
profiting from this war while innocent
civilians in the Gaza Strip and in isra
Isel bear the cost and are murdered so
if there's anyone we should be pointing
a finger at and looking at it's the
people pulling the strings on top
because if you actually speak to the
Israelis or the Palestinians nobody
wants this war it's just the government
because at the end of the day war is
extremely profitable so I'm going to
share my unique story with you so in May
2021 I actually tried to move to Israel
while I was there attempting to find a
place to live the war broke out and I
saw Rockets just exploding above me it
was something out of Star Wars I was
then woken up at 3:00 a.m. by Sirens
it's 3:00 in the morning and I'm hiding
under these stairs of an old building in
Tel Aviv as Rockets rained on me it was
at that moment that I asked myself is
there anything I can do to fix this
situation and I realized there's nothing
that I can do I'm just one individual
there's nothing anyone could do whether
you're Israeli Jewish Muslim Palestinian
Arab whatever it is this is beyond us as
individuals this is a game being played
by the two governments I thought to
myself who can I call I thought can I
can I call the prime minister of Israel
and ask him to stop can I call Hamas and
ask him to stop there's no one you can
call because it has nothing to do with
us we're just innocent civilians on both
sides so engaging in all this debate
saying slogans like free Palestine
saying flatten all of them in Gaza it's
not going to do anything it's just more
divide and conquer as I sat there in the
bomb shelter with rockets reigning over
me I realize that we are powerless and
guess what I sat there with Muslims I
sat there with with Palestinians who
were also terrified we got on we were
hugging we were terrified nobody wants
this war go speak to anyone on the
ground we're not divided we love each
other it's the people on top that push
this war that push the propaganda free
your mind there's no point in taking
sides the only side to take is a side of
peace and love of your fellow citizen
the war is being played out as a game of
chess by people above us and the only
solution that I can think of to take the
power back from the those are the top is
to simply not engage is to not take
sides is to not fuel the online war that
we're seeing you have to refuse to be
manipulated you have to take a step back
and actually witness the games being
played on top and once more more people
adopt this mentality I believe that
eventually people will put their guns
down because they'll say what's the
point why are we killing other innocent
people what just so the people on top
can make all this money while everybody
else suffers once we open our minds to
actually see what's going on here I
truly believe people will put their guns
down honestly guys leaving Israel was
one of the best things that I did I
don't understand why you'd want to sit
in a war zone I feel that you have a
responsibility to yourself and your
family before your government and your
religion I didn't personally want to
live in a place where it would disrupt
my life and I would have bombs being
reigned on me all day I refused to be a
victim and so that is why I decided to
leave Israel I think everybody should
refuse to be a victim and should look to
prosper and not get caught up in all
this ideological war which as I've said
doesn't benefit any of us at the end of
the day so I hope that shed some light
on the situation for you guys I did try
and remain as objective as possible and
I hope you enjoyed my personal
experience it's actually not something
that I've publicly shared before so
there you go now on the note of opening
your mind we do have an incredible
podcast coming out next week with Luke
belma so make sure to hit the like
button and subscribe so you don't miss
this video